hey so uh two quick questions uh here so
the first question about like hiring
slow and firing fast regarding like
women but when you're vetting women
you're dating them all that
um i've experienced this a couple of
times and i'm curious if you have two
where people tell you
oh rich or spencer i think your your
expectations your standards are too high
and you're being too hard on other
people and you're commanding
you know too much because who's saying
that to you is that your family
or for friends uh a friend in this
specific situation i'm thinking of like
a
close uh co-worker and friend um
and um i'm pretty hard on myself i
i'm you know physically and like my my
work habits and everything i
i set pretty high goals and expectations
so
i invariably apply that to people that
i'm that are surrounded by my
surrounded by me right because you want
to have good positive healthy people
around you
and um it's you know as we've
discussed on the show and people have
said it's it's hard to surround yourself
with positive people that are a good
influence it can be
you know depending on where you're at in
the world or in the country in your
workplace
it can be difficult so especially when
it comes to women if you're trying to
let them into your life
um closely um i'll just receive
you know you're gonna get that right i
mean like if you set strict
strict boundaries about who you're gonna
allow in your inner circle whether it's
employees whether it's women whether
it's friends
especially with women and if you're
getting you know if you're getting older
and your family or friends have certain
expectations of you you know societal
expectations so you got to find one and
settle down and have kids
you know be miserable like everybody
else sort of thing and
you're like well i got rid of her
because she was crazy or i got rid of
her because
she was a feminazi or i got rid of her
because i don't like
uh you know women that don't put a
priority on self-care and they're
getting fat or whatever right like
these are like it's your life right and
the thing that you got to get your head
around as a dude as you're navigating
again your life is are you making
yourself your own mental point of origin
with every choice with every day with
every week with every month and year
are you are you continuing to making to
to to making choices that align with
things that serve you and it's very very
different when guys start to unplug from
the bullcrap and start to make
themselves their own mental point of
origin because people will criticize you
you will lose friends they're going to
start to challenge you you know why are
you being so picky spencer you know
what's wrong with
jill jill was a good girl why didn't you
pick jill like you know
what the hell was wrong with her well
she had
two kids in tow from two different
fathers that's what's wrong with her
okay so stop bothering me piss off right
um you just have to be firm with them
right like you have to hold firm strong
boundaries and if you set
high standards for yourself you're going
to do far better in the world but at the
same time
you're also going to tolerate less crap
and you're going to have more criticism
um you know of your choices because of
those higher standards right
people people generally speaking have
very low standards you know for
themselves
and for the world i mean look at the
world right now
we're in a lockdown state for something
that you can only see it under a
microscope
that only get like 99 points some like
eight percent of uh
people survive if they get it but we're
in complete lockdown because everybody
wants to be a [ __ ]
right so we don't have very very high
standards for ourselves and society you
know we want to weaken society and learn
it's like
you know in a school gym where the
basketball net was too high and the kids
couldn't you know dunk it they would
just lower the basketball net
that's what we're doing right now and
when you hold yourself to higher
standards in
in life you've got to understand that
that people will
point and sputter at you right
yeah for sure uh so kind of a second
question do you have any thoughts or
maybe
you know how i could apply this to or
how
the viewers can apply this say you're an
employee so say you're not a supervisor
yet so you're just a
you know professional in a corporate
environment so on i mean
you're not gonna be doing any firing
obviously but there is this mindset
applicable somehow
because obviously in the corporate world
especially if you're not a supervisor
you do have to play the game right if
you if you run the business
or you have free ram free reign from
your employer
you can do whatever you want you know
you can fire people when you want but
the problem is is that if you're a
supervisor manager working for a large
corporation
they make you jump through all kinds of
like i remember when i was working
in the credit and collection world i
think we had something like 600
seats in the office and most of them
were filled most of the time
um i would routinely like people would
routinely shuffle around staff that were
problem
and rather than firing them right what
do they do they just move them out of
their department
so every couple months i got some loser
that
was utterly useless that i would try to
train that i would find that i was
wasting my time on
and that i would want to fire and
interestingly
lower level employees are quite a bit
harder to fire
than like managers like at the manager
level that
that i was at because it was president
vp uh
and then it was the department manager
so i was one of the department managers
in a
in a office that had 600 people um
it was a lot easier to fire a guy like
me because of fit because when head
office you know comes down and says okay
we need to cut
uh manager salary off the uh budget
you know they just kind of look around
and go well who are we butting heads
with and it's like this guy over here
who's the office defenestrator
he's the guy that gets you know the can
so they actually move managers out at
least once a year in most large
businesses like that especially where
they have to cut back but
lower level employees you're gonna have
a harder time moving them out unless
you've got free rein from your boss or
you run your own business
i used to fire people quickly my own
business man like
i remember um there was this one guy
that was screwing the pooch and he was a
sales guy
and um i caught him what was that
website i think it was called hot or not
or some
some nonsense like that he would spend
his an entire afternoon
i'm paying the dude to do a job he spent
his entire afternoon
surfing the internet on this hot or not
on like
gay and transvestite stuff and i'm like
you're not doing your job i don't care
what you're doing you're completely
distracted you're getting out of here
pissed off right
you know you got to cut the guy a uh
check because you know there's severance
pay and all this sort of stuff but you
know when you start to see that somebody
is an utter and complete train wreck
like they're an anchor in your business
and your life and your friends circle if
you know if it's a woman get rid of them
and don't look back
trust me yeah for sure
you